what a year it's been it's been
absolutely crazy i guess it's the right
word for it but especially
for you you turned uh 30 you had a baby
this
and endemic it's all long to use
how are you doing mind body and soul
i'm good i i definitely miss being on
the road and
you know having something to do every
day but um no it's been nice i i get to
hang out with my husband and our baby
and we've gotten a lot of family time in
the last few months
which has been great and uh yeah you
know
slowly but surely starting to write
songs again which makes me feel like a
normal person
um but yeah what about you yeah yeah i'm
doing okay i'm doing all right you know
the kids are healthy so
life is good thanks for asking i really
appreciate that um
yeah and there's just that's right
there's a silver lining to it all is the
fact that you do have that time with
your kids
and for you how is it to see your little
one grow
um it's i know everyone says this and
it's cliche but it just does
happen so quickly um he's gonna be five
months in a couple of days which you
know
i had him at the beginning of covid
really kicking off so
it's just crazy like the time has been
slow and also has flown by this
party august but no he's getting so big
he's i feel like he's gonna be tall like
his dad
um like he doesn't fit in his age
size of clothing anymore um
but um no he's adorable and he's so
smiley and
sweet right now and hopefully it stays
like that
forever they do they do i have a 13 year
old and a 10 year old and they're
they're still kind of cute they're kind
of cute i guess so as they get older
uh but you know i just want to say thank
you for actually talking about your
experience the fact that you
you were in labor for 30 hours you had a
c-section you
you know you threw this pandemic where
people couldn't visit you at the
hospital then you talk about
postpartum which i can totally relate to
in a time like this and as and you said
it's been
almost five months what have you learned
about yourself through this
um you know i've gone through so many
waves like i'm sure as you know
after you have a baby there's just so
many hormonal
uh things that are trying to level back
out and it takes
time and um i think just what i can
physically and emotionally withstand i i
feel like my threshold is way higher
than i
once thought and um
i think like i've grown more patient
over the month
because i've had to you know not only
with a baby but
just with life kind of shutting down
i've had to
really take a pause and figure out you
know things i love outside of music
and um and touring and so i feel like
it's just
out of necessity taught me to be more
patient and not rush to the next thing
yeah it's it's crazy because you're
redefining yourself as a mom
and you're changing your identity right
essentially that's what's happening when
you're having your child
what's a message to new moms that are
out there now that what you've learned
i would i guess what i've learned is
that you know
you join this amazing club of women that
have gone through this
insanely physical emotionally taxing
thing
and you're joining a club of women that
um
support you and have gone through pretty
much exactly what you've gone through
and
there's always someone that will get it
and uh
and also you know i i've found this like
tribe of
friends of mine that are mothers that
i've never gotten to connect with on
this level before and i've been friends
for years but it's so so rewarding to be
able to talk to them about these really
deep
issues um that i never really understood
before
so i feel like it's brought a lot of my
mom friends
closer it's good to have that group of
people and you get to watch your husband
become a dad
like how cool is that yeah it's like
weird but it is kind of the hottest
thing it's just to see isn't it
you're a guy like holding a baby and
taking care of it
it's just like it's like completely like
natured response to be like
wow you're really hot ah i love that
and you talk you know one of the great
things about kids is the fashion i
love that you posted the jean jacket
that was given to you by miranda
how cute is that is it one of the best
gifts you've gotten
oh yeah i mean it's i love that it's
personalized it's
blinged out i mean he looks like a
little baby elton john
in it i'm i'm so excited to to
hopefully you know it'll still fit him
when we can go out and he can show it
off
mm-hmm did you get your own you got your
own too right there's one yeah everyone
knows what they have matching
you have matching ones yeah and how how
my husband's like oh yeah what son
wouldn't want to match with his mother
[Laughter]
and how is it going on social media now
it's good you know i i've been a step
back with
um sharing you know face photos of haze
but
i kind of like that you know i can still
share that facet of me that is a mom and
like loves her
sweet little baby but i think it was
probably time
even though it was a little forced i i
feel like it was time to just
give him privacy now that he's getting a
little bit bigger
and uh we'd always planned on doing that
at some point with him but
it just came a little sooner than we
hoped but
no it's great like i feel like i can
still share him
but still keep his his um anonymity
mm-hmm and you talked about the fact
that you're creating music right now and
i think he tweeted uh
i it's sad as af i'm so happy
is that just all about mom life well i
mean i just
even if i'm like the happiest person in
the world i write the saddest songs i
don't know why it's not like
synonymous with my mood that day it just
happens to come out really sad if i'm
happy and then
i'll be sad and want to write a happy
song so
but that would be a good mix i hope of
both on that on the new record
if you were to write a song right now
what would the title be about your life
tired i don't know i love that
i don't know tired is a good one but you
shouldn't be tired because you're
releasing reimagine
which is a a stripped-down version of
your
massive hits uh girl to the bones and
you have such a
powerful voice what is it like for you
as an artist to see your voice
in this way an acoustic version so which
one do you like better do you like the
original one or the acoustic version
oh that's hard i mean obviously like the
original makes me
happy because that's what we put so much
time
and love into to make it sound like that
but then
you know i i feel like the reimagined
project reminds me of my
writing demos which are extremely bare
and don't have a bunch of flash and
production i like kind of getting to do
both and
i i feel like it it reminds me that
you know i love to sing it doesn't have
to have a bunch of bells and whistles on
it
to to sound good and um yeah it kind of
brings me back to my roots to do the
the acoustic stuff yeah it's beautiful i
love it
and you know you gotta you get some
recognition from acm awards you know
female artist of the year album of the
year i mean
no big deal right i mean this is huge
oh thank you i it's going to be a weird
year going into all of that stuff
with it being you know still in the
middle of the pandemic but
they seem to be doing it creatively and
so we can
all celebrate this year of music and do
it in a fun way where
the artists and the fans and the
musicians and writers can all like
really
take a moment and celebrate even in the
middle of a weird near
the work that we've done i think
miranda's in both categories as well
is she i think she is yeah she always
is and i love wild cards so much
so i'm so excited to we'll be a part of
that record as well with our duet
and then um have my own in there i love
that
what brings you joy um
i mean obviously writing songs has
brought me a ton of joy
especially as of late with everything
slowing down
um and obviously my my baby and my
husband
bring me a ton of joy and
lots of ice cream in this downtime and
uh
netflix yeah favorite flavor do you have
a favorite food
it rotates but right now i'm into the
i love chocolate cherry garcia i love
fish food
it's like the the band fish has
ice cream flavor um from ben and jerry's
yeah it's it's been broken so you're
working on an album right now
tell us about that well it's obviously
extremely early
i uh after winning album at the cmas
last fall i kind of was able to give
myself a second to
to chill and step back and um and then
have a baby but i
have been very slowly i've written like
four or five songs
it takes a while to to get like enough
in the batch to
create a record like i usually write
like 50 to 60
songs to get down to those like album
cuts but um
yeah we'll see i mean as of right now
the ones that i've written
have been really soulful and um
a little less like pop um
a little more rootsy so i don't know if
that's just a sign of the times and like
what's around me and uh me just kind of
wanting to
really re-tap into my songwriter-e-ness
or text-in-ness
but i i'm excited to kind of see where
it goes production-wise and
thematically but yeah i'll keep you
posted as we get in there but it's very
very early stages
and do you feel the pressure of success
after the success you've had with girl
um you know i've kind of withered away
all the stress and anxiety of trying to
one-up myself
because i learned you know even after my
first record
with my church um you can't really
recreate
that moment twice and so uh once that
kind of anxiety went away when i put my
second record out
it just unveils itself in new ways like
i never thought the bones would end up
being
as big as big as it was and um be across
like multiple
genre platforms but yeah it's been so
rewarding and so i
i just kind of stopped putting a ceiling
or expectation on
my creativity and my art so i just want
to kind of see what happens and then
i have no control over the reception all
i know is like
i will love it before i ever let anyone
hear it
you